[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le cetud choisir votre numéro dédié
aux idées sorties tout de suite le
sommaire de ce vendredi 16 mars dix
jours de concerts d'expositions d'humour
et de conte musical 16e édition du
festival à tout bout de champ à magny
les hameaux
jusqu'au 25 mars une programmation
accessible dès 3 ans notre invité rachel
benoît organisatrice du festival
nous vous en parlera devenez capitaine
ou voyager en wagons sans quitter
montigny le bretonneux deux associations
de modélisme ne vous font découvrir
leurs créations ce week end une
exposition à vivre en miniature et dans
notre rendez-vous junior mélanie poquet
nous présentera deux événements un
concert rock avec des jouets pour
enfants ce sera deux oies kids à
maurepas et un spectacle jeunesse à
coignières pour découvrir souliers de
sable mais avant un rendez vous sportif
la traditionnelle le courses du
printemps de voisins-le-bretonneux
s'élancera ce dimanche à 9h30
plusieurs parcours sont proposés le 15
km course nature à l'esprit trail la
grande ville chinoise de 6 km et l'après
midi ce sont les plus jeunes qui sont
invités à se dépenser
la course des années collège s'est doté
d'un nouveau parcours de 3 km et la
journée se terminera par les rondes vie
sinoise pour les enfants en classes de
primaire
vous avez encore jusqu'à dimanche matin
pour vous inscrire auprès du centre
alfred de vigny une journée à vivre en
famille selon l'animateur de cette
course
la chance qu'ils ont les athlètes qui
vont être au départ dimanche et de
traverser l'abbaye du port royal qui est
un site historique ou très connu dans la
région est très visitée et l'après midi
c'est vraiment je dirais le le
le bonheur de toute la famille parce que
il suffit d'être au départ et à
l'arrivée pour voir que ea est le papa
la maman les grands parents les frères
les soeurs c'est vraiment une ambiance
très bon enfant là on est vraiment loin
de la compétition du matin je dirais non
là c'est pas du tout le même esprit
serons-nous humains demain c'est la
question posée pour la deuxième édition
des rencontres
insiteo théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 17 au 25
mars des spectacles des conférences des
projections pour réfléchir autour de
cette thématique de l'humain de demain
une programmation qui mêle arts et
sciences approche sensible et
intellectuelle
lionel masséna en charge de ces
rencontres était cette semaine sur le
plateau du 7-8 culture ces rencontres in
cité c'est comme un instrument un outil
de partage du savoir et pour partager le
savoir un avis des scientifiques des
artistes l'idée c'était de pouvoir
éclairer une thématique scientifique ou
pas mais enfin d'éclairer une thématique
par le regard des scientifiques des
chercheurs toutes disciplines
scientifiques confondues le regard des
artistes ils regardent des réalisateurs
qui sont eux-mêmes des artistes et on
voit souvent que les artistes ont
parfois anticiper un certain nombre de
recherches qui ont lu aujourd'hui donc
c'est assez assez intéressant de
confronter ces trois points de vue
[Musique]
16e édition du festival à tout bout de
champ à magny les hameaux
exposition humour concerts et comédie
musicale un festival qui mêle différents
médiums pour faire découvrir l'art sous
toutes ses formes
notre invité cette semaine rachel benoît
en charge de la programmation jeune
public de la ville pour nous en parler
quand le frère aux moyens techniques
nous sommes la maison de l'environnement
de magny les hameaux avec rachel benoît
programmatrice ce jeune public pour la
ville le festival à tout bout de champ a
débuté cette semaine jusqu'au 25 mars
encore une programmation riche et
accessible dès 3 ans c'est vraiment pour
les plus jeunes ce festival
alors pour les plus jeunes et leurs
familles on a huit compagnies qui
viennent sur le festival sur quinze
jours dont une création qui est fait
pour les enfants par les enfants avec
gan enseignants in dumiste voilà hier on
a débuté par une conférence dansée et un
bal de la même compagnie sixième
dimension et qui a eu un super succès
aujourd'hui on est avec nous la black
soul de la compagnie tous métis demain
on est avec tonicello qui traite qui est
un interprète de chansons et surtout qui
m lle l'humour qui était avant prof de
collège donc il sait et il a intégré
totalement une classe de cm2 de la ville
dans son spectacle beaucoup de choses à
voir et notamment des concerts aussi il
y aura un concert ce samedi à 17h avec
zut alors qu'est ce que c'est alors
lisez les huttes tout le monde les
connaît dans là c'est vraiment un groupe
reconnu dans le spectacle des jeunes
publics
ils traînent leurs valises depuis très
très longtemps et c'est du rock c'est
festif et c'est aussi alors le
traitement la de leurs concerts
spécifique c'est le petit bug le petit
caillou dans la chaussure
le petit la petite chose qui n'a pas
d'importance mais qu'ils nous embêtent
voilà ils viennent traiter ça avec les
enfants de façon intelligente et donc
beaucoup d'humour a aussi c'est ça ce
festival parce qu'il ya aussi il a
ouvert en fait avec le hip hop est ce
bien sérieux donc une conférence dansée
vous en avez parlé et mardi mercredi
prochain vous proposez aussi un
spectacle burlesque
oui alors les boîtes à gants on les a
découvert au festival au bonheur des
mômes et c'est un moment très festif
dans le sol il raconte une histoire il y
as avec toute l'élégance qui sont perdus
et brefs et il raconte des histoires et
ils finissent par une bataille de grand-
puisque les grands on en trouve toujours
partout et c'est comme les chaussettes
on en perd toujours aux unions sais pas
où j'ai vraiment beaucoup d'humour a
donc l'idée de ce festival servant de
faire découvrir la musique mais pas
seulement des plus jeune âge en fait un
petit différend en différents types
d'armes
il faut une forme d'art alors comme on
peut le voir là on est dans la maison
d'environnement où on a une exposition
faite par les quinze classes de magny
les hameaux et qui ont accueilli
charlotte de long qui est plasticienne
qui a déjà travaillé avec nous
et elle aura fait apprendre et découvrir
surtout la méthode la vie c'est une
méthode de l'eau puisque notre thème
cette année c'est au fil de l'eau au fil
de l'eau parce qu'on a la compagnie tous
métis et qui traite qui traite du
mississippi on a lucioles aussi qui
travaille dessus
voilà donc on s'est dit ce grand thème
au fil de l'eau était vraiment on l'a
déclinée sur l'art plastique
il ya toujours une exposition dans le
festival jeune public c est une manière
d'impliquer le public que l'on essaye de
toucher les parents sont très fiers de
voir le travail qu'ils ont mené les
enseignants sont super partant pour
travailler avec les artistes donc c'est
vraiment un bon moment le l'exposition à
tout bout de champ oui mon convoi en
plus ce qui est accessible au public et
donc on a justement une classe qu en
train de visiter de regarder les oeuvres
vous en avez parlé en vraiment ce
festival c'est la seizième édition et
c'est vraiment devenu un rendez vous
incontournable pour la vie marquant même
toutes les classes sont mobilisés tous
les élèves de la ville sont mobilisés
est ce qu'on essaye c'est que chaque
classe voit un spectacle après c'est
aussi sur volonté donc c'est sur
inscription mais en tout cas il ya
beaucoup de monde qui participent les
classes en partant pour pleins pleins à
découvrir plein de spectacles très
différents les uns des autres et pour
tous les âges
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on n'a aussi
boîte à gants à partir de 2 ans boîte à
gants qui nous permet aussi d'accueillir
les crèches et donc vous l'avez évoqué
également lucioles non ça c'est le
spectacle de fin à celui qui va clore le
festival a le 25 mars donc une comédie
musicale
et pour les gourmands un goûter juste
après la représentation alors lui sial
c'est un spectacle tout public
dites adultes et simplement elle est
venue travailler avec le collège de
maninday
oh et puis les professeurs de musique et
de français pour créer une chanson
les collégiens donc on a eu une classe
de 4e qui a travaillé pour l'écriture
d'une chanson sur bat toujours le thème
au fil de l'eau ils ont choisi
l'histoire d'une petite rivière qui qui
grandit et qui fait tout un chemin qui
fait son road-movie et voilà ils ont
écrit cette chanson qu'ils vont
interpréter avec lui seul sur scène pour
clore le festival ont clos souvent avec
les collégiens et cette année c'est avec
lucio lit les collégiens support au fil
de l'eau va parfait en tout cas le
rendez vous est pris merci beaucoup
rachel benoît d'avoir développé avec
nous donc à cette programmation du
festival à tout bout de champ donc il se
déroule on le rappelle jusqu'au 25 mars
et l'ensemble des spectacles et des
informations est à retrouver sur le site
internet de magny les hameaux
[Musique]
et c'est un rendez-vous des juniors
rock'n'roll qui vous attend mélanie vous
avez un spectacle à découvrir dès 6 ans
à nous proposer
c'est ça les wackids ils viennent de
tous deux terminé à un tour
intergalactique quatre ans 400 concerts
il pose enfin leurs instruments à
l'espace albert camus de maurepas alors
c'est un groupe de rock composé de super
héros ou jaune et bleu et ils ont une
particularité il joue avec des jouets
d'enfants de regarder
[Musique]
moi j'imagine québec vous avez reconnu
johnny be good appuyé cette reprise est
vraiment super mignonne avec les
instruments à sa rentrée certains
d'entre eux seulement vaut mieux un film
un petit peu d'enfance mais alors
bluesmaster bongo star et speed fingers
et les artistes
ils ont bien d'autres morceaux à vous
faire découvrir et d'en désordre yellow
submarine bohemian rhapsody bat biking
blague alors plein d'humour et
d'originalité vous l'avez vu les plus
jeunes vont sans doute vouloir rentrer
et testé quand ils seront à la maison
les plus grands auront peut-être un
petit goût de nostalgie le début du show
c'est à 20h30 et samedi 17 mars à ma
femme et à coignières ce sera un petit
moment de poésie et de tendresse
là c'est la manivelle théâtre qui vous
fait découvrir l'histoire des lise et
léo il vu seul à l'abri depuis toujours
dans leur quotidien est rythmé par des
grains de sable
mais un matin les eaux laisse s'échapper
leurs chaussures et pour les retrouver
ils partent vers l'extérieur et ils vont
alors découvrez les trésors de la nature
et de la nuit regarder
[Musique]
la cage des fermières klich n'est pas
l'habit je ne peux pas
oh
mais ne connaît pas les pierres qui vous
dormez
se perdent et grave
[Musique]
où
soulié de salles c'est à voir à partir
deux trois ans ça permet de révéler ce
qui se cache derrière les peurs des
enfants lever de rideau à 17 heures au
théâtre alphonse daudet de quoi dire et
comme toujours toutes les informations à
retrouver sur les sites internet de
maurepas et de coignières merci mélanie
pour ces rendez vous on passe maintenant
à notre agenda avec une soirée disco à
noter
chaussez vos patins pour une soirée
disco roller à elancourt sur le thème de
la saint patrick les chocs se vous donne
rendez vous au gymnase chastagner de 18
heures à 22 heures ce samedi 17 mars
buvette animations et tombola sont
également au programme le 7 8 loisirs
est maintenant terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis nous espérons que vous avez
fait le plein d'idées sorties en famille
ou entre amis on se retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro et je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
oui